be
it seems like there's no safety in that
garage at all that former employee at
Reed International Airport saying they
wouldn't park their car there that
person coming forward after the 8 News
investigators exposed thieves sealing
cars from the airport's garages tonight
we reveal the startling incident no one
at the airport caught for weeks
the odor around the vehicle is pretty
it's pretty horrific but that horrific
smell is a
human being yeah we're gonna need to
coroner and ID please it's November 1st
a Las Vegas metro police officer's body
camera records as he investigates the
discovery here in the terminal one
parking garage at Harry Reid
International Airport
pickup in it
yeah short-term short-term passenger
pickup the woman died by suicide in this
car parked just a few dozen feet away
from the pickup area according to the
airport's website it's a part of the
garage quote intended for stays of three
hours or less yeah she's been there a
while 23 days or more than 500 hours
past that three hour limit what do you
think the biggest issue is when it comes
to security and safety at the airport
parking garages there needs to be more
presents out there
Patrol we are concealing this former
Department of Aviation employees
identity over their fear of retaliation
they say they weren't surprised this car
sat here with a woman's body inside in
short-term parking for more than three
weeks how does something like that go
undetected for 23 days you're supposed
to do
an inventory on the short-term parking
and obviously somebody just went and
that's what did they never actually
verified if that particular vehicle has
been there and how long it's been there
a report obtained by the 8 news now
investigator shows there was a record of
the car entering the garage on October
8th it wasn't until the smell of Decay
permeated the area 23 days later that a
parking employee alerted police it's
unclear if the car was inventoried and
if it was why no one checked on it
especially when parked so close to an
area so many passed by to come you know
to the airport and leave for a couple
days and come back in your vehicles
missing it's terrible it's a terrible
feeling in November the 8 news now
investigators revealed thieves have
stolen dozens of cars from the airport
over the past two years we interviewed
an airport spokesperson about that but
unknown to us that interview happened
the day after that officer recorded this
video we don't know how long she's been
deceased a lot of different components
in place to you know check on the
vehicles keep them safe we have people
who go through at night check the
license plates that are here to you know
again keep that information and see what
vehicles we have on property our former
employee says Staffing shortages and
automation have led to fewer patrols
there'll be something that's where
um when they have bike control that they
may only have one an airport
spokesperson says while short-term
parking is meant for a stay under three
hours a car can actually be parked there
for 30 days while the car in question
was logged pulling into the garage it's
unclear if there's other surveillance
available reports for stolen cars the 8
news now investigators obtained show a
lack of surveillance in the garages with
one person reporting their car missing
with quote no record of the vehicle
leaving for there to be
several of these reports that say that
there was no surveillance yeah
is that acceptable you know I can't
speak to the reports I haven't seen them
so I can't speak to to what is behind
that the oral camera still at the garage
most of them are preset in certain
direction so
if something does happen there's a
chance it may or may not be caught on
camera while some theft reports we
obtained indicate daily car inventories
have happened it's unclear why this car
went unnoticed our former employee says
staff isn't allowed to look inside
Vehicles nor could they see if the
windows were obscured would you park
your car there you require us no I just
don't feel that my vehicle would be safe
out there
we do know the sunroof was open on that
car we have been asking what specific
improvements the department of Aviation
is making inside those garages we were
told last year camera upgrades are part
of a multi-year Improvement project and
we did find Clark County Commission
agenda items for that multi-million
dollar project which was partly funded
with the TSA for video camera and
storage upgrades but we can't find any
specifics other than the number of
cameras in garages doubled but we don't
know how many cameras were installed
what their maintenance costs are or if
they're even working right now we will
continue to get to these answers for our
next report police previously telling us
more than 2 million cars parked on the
property in 2021 noting while car thefts
do happen they are rare